knowing that you have two children what
15 and 18 13 and 17 13 17 okay I'm sorry
14 and 17 okay you must have thought
about your own family during the making
of this and being a parent can you talk
about the most emotional moment during
your years collecting the interviews for
kids for cash I'd say the most emotional
moment was listening to the kids to
other stories and you know feeling so
helpless that the first thing they all
talked about was the the moment they
were handcuffed and shackled and it was
for them to tell that story was just all
of us it got us all I mean our whole
team would just be just be we have the
energy sucked out of us because they
wouldn't even talk about the scandal
first I mean the scandal was secondary
the first thing was handcuffed and
Jacqueline and the and the fact that
they were being pulled away from their
families it was incredible and then you
know I'd go home to my kids and I would
think about cheese it could be them it
really could be them and how would we
feel and and how would the kids feel and
when a kid is taken in the juvenile
system the parents lose all custody and
control of their kid there's nothing
they can do once that kid is adjudicated
delinquent so knowing that knowing that
you went back what would you have done I
mean there were some instances where
there were just the parents are going
down with the kids for a meeting and
then they ended up being taken away I
believe so could you tell what maybe you
would have done if suppose one of your
children had gotten in trouble whether
it was a minor scuffle at school
something like that and you were put in
this position well I would be a lot of
the parents that went there thought was
going to work out okay and they were
surprised when their kid was you know
hauled away and handcuffs and shackles
we screened the film in Omaha and we
there was a parent that spoke up at the
end and they said their son went before
a juvenile court judge in Omaha and the
kid couldn't speak he was so frightened
he couldn't speak to the parents were
trying to help him and speak up for him
and the judge warned them twice to keep
their mouth shut and let the kid talk
but the third time the parents pokes the
judge literally had the parents
handcuffed shackled and arrested and
taken out of the courtroom in front of
the kid and then shortly thereafter
arrested the kid as well I would have
been that parent I would have been the
parent that would have literally said to
the you know judge you wait a minute but
a lot of these parents were threatened
with being hauled out of the courtroom
didn't keep their mouth shut that's what
would happen to me they would they would
have had to restrain me and take me out
of the court but that happened to
parents
you